- [Voiceover] So we've already started to
familiarize ourselves
with the notion of charge.
We've seen that if two
things have the same charge,
so they're either both positive,
or they are both negative,
then they are going to repel each other.
So in either of these cases
these things are going
to repel each other.
But if they have different charges,
they are going to attract each other.
So if I have a positive
and I have a negative
they are going to attract each other.
This charge is a property of matter
that we've started to observe.
We've started to observe of
how these different charges,
this framework that we've created,
how these things start to
interact with each other.
So these things are going to,
these two things are going
to attract each other.
But the question is, what causes,
how can we predict how strong the force
of attraction or repulsion is going to be
between charged particles?
And this was a question
people have noticed,
I guess what you could
call electrostatics,
for a large swathe of
recorded human history.
But it wasn't until the 16 hundreds
and especially the 17 hundreds,
that people started to seriously view this
as something that they could manipulate
and even start to predict
in a kind of serious,
mathematical, scientific way.
And it wasn't until
1785, and there were many
that came before Coulomb,
but in 1785 Coulomb formally published
what is known as Coulomb's law.
And the purpose of Coulomb's law,
Coulomb's law,
is to predict what is
going to be the force of
the electrostatic force
of attraction or repulsion
between two forces.
And so in Coulomb's law, what it states is
is if I have two charges,
so let me, let's say this
charge right over here,
and I'm gonna make it in white,
because it could be positive or negative,
but I'll just make it q
one, it has some charge.
And then I have in Coulombs.
and then another charge
q two right over here.
Another charge, q two.
And then I have the distance
between them being r.
So the distance between these two charges
is going to be r.
Coulomb's law states that the force,
that the magnitude of the force,
so it could be a repulsive force
or it could be an attractive force,
which would tell us the
direction of the force
between the two charges,
but the magnitude of the force,
which I'll just write it as F,
the magnitude of the electrostatic force,
I'll write this sub e here,
this subscript e for electrostatic.
Coulomb stated, well this is going to be,
and he tested this, he didn't
just kind of guess this.
People actually were assuming
that it had something
to do with the products of the magnitude
of the charges and that as the particles
got further and further away
the electrostatic force dissipated.
But he was able to actually measure this
and feel really good
about stating this law.
Saying that the magnitude
of the electrostatic force
is proportional,
to the product of the
magnitudes of the charges.
So I could write this
as q one times q two,
and I could take the
absolute value of each,
which is the same thing as just
taking the absolute value of the product.
Here's why I'm taking the
absolute value of the product,
well, if they're different charges,
this will be a negative number,
but we just want the overall
magnitude of the force.
So we could take, it's proportional to
the absolute value of the
product of the charges
and it's inversely proportional to
not just the distance between them,
not just to r, but to the
square of the distance.
The square of the distance between them.
And what's pretty neat about this
is how close it mirrors
Newton's law of gravitation.
Newton's law of gravitation,
we know that the force,
due to gravity between two masses,
remember mass is just
another property of matter,
that we sometimes feel is
a little bit more tangible
because it feels like we can
kind of see weight and volume,
but that's not quite the same,
or we feel like we can feel or
internalize things like weight and volume
which are related to mass,
but in some ways it is
just another property,
another property, especially
as you get into more
of a kind of fancy physics.
Our everyday notion of even mass starts to
become a lot more interesting.
But Newton's law of gravitation says,
look the magnitude of the force of gravity
between two masses is going
to be proportional to,
by Newton's, by the gravitational concept,
proportional to the
product of the two masses.
Actually, let me do it
in those same colors
so you can see the relationship.
It's going to be proportional to
the product of the two
masses, m one m two.
And it's going to be
inversely proportional
to the square of the distance.
The square of the distance
between two masses.
Now these proportional
personality constants
are very different. Gravitational force,
we kind of perceive this
is as acting, being strong,
it's a weaker force in close range.
But we kind of imagine it
as kind of what dictates
what happens in the,
amongst the stars and
the planets and moons.
While the electrostatic
force at close range
is a much stronger force.
It can overcome the
gravitational force very easily.
But it's what we consider happening
at either an atomic level
or kind of at a scale
that we are more familiar to operating at.
But needless to say,
it is very interesting
to see how this parallel
between these two things,
it's kind of these
patterns in the universe.
But with that said, let's actually apply
let's actually apply Coulomb's law,
just to make sure we feel
comfortable with the mathematics.
So let's say that I have a charge here.
Let's say that I have a charge here,
and it has a positive
charge of, I don't know,
let's say it is positive five
times 10 to the negative three Coulombs.
So that's this one right over here.
That's its charge.
And let's say I have this
other charge right over here
and this has a negative charge.
And it is going to be,
it is going to be, let's
say it's negative one...
Negative one times 10
to the negative one Coulombs.
And let's say that the
distance between the two,
let's that this distance right here
is 0.5 meters.
So given that, let's figure out what the
what the electrostatic force
between these two are going to be.
And we can already predict that
it's going to be an
attractive force because
they have different signs.
And that was actually
part of Coulomb's law.
This is the magnitude of the force,
if these have different
signs, it's attractive,
if they have the same sign then they
are going to repel each other.
And I know what you're saying,
"Well in order to actually calculate it,
"I need to know what K is."
What is this electrostatic constant?
What is this electrostatic
constant going to actually be?
And so you can measure that
with a lot of precision,
and we have kind of modern numbers on it,
but the electrostatic constant,
especially for the sake of this problem,
I mean if we were to get
really precise it's 8.987551,
we could keep gone on and
on times 10 to the ninth.
But for the sake of our
little example here,
where we really only have
one significant digit for each of these.
Let's just get an approximation,
it'll make the math a little bit easier,
I won't have to get a calculator out,
let's just say it's approximately
nine times 10 to the ninth.
Nine times 10 to the ninth.
Nine times, actually let me
make sure it says approximately,
because I am approximating here,
nine times 10 to the ninth.
And what are the units going to be?
Well in the numerator here,
where I multiply Coulombs times Coulombs,
I'm going to get Coulombs squared.
This right over here is going to give me,
that's gonna give me Coulombs squared.
And this down over here is going
to give me meters squared.
This is going to give me meters squared.
And what I want is to get rid of
the Coulombs and the meters and end up
with just the Newtons.
And so the units here are actually,
the units here are Newtons.
Newton and then meters squared,
and that cancels out
with the meters squared
in the denominator.
Newton meter squared over Coulomb squared.
Over, over Coulomb squared.
Let me do that in white.
So, these meter squared will cancel those.
Those Coulomb squared in the denomin...
over here will cancel with those,
and you'll be just left with Newtons.
But let's actually do that.
Let's apply it to this example.
I encourage you to pause the video
and apply this information
to Coulomb's law
and figure out what
the electrostatic force
between these two
particles is going to be.
So I'm assuming you've had your go at it.
So it is going to be, and this is really
just applying the formula.
It's going to be nine
times 10 to the ninth,
nine times 10 to the ninth,
and I'll write the units here,
Newtons meter squared
over Coulomb squared.
And then q one times q two,
so this is going to be,
let's see, this is going to be,
actually let me just write
it all out for this first
this first time.
So it's going to be times five times ten
to the negative three Coulombs.
Times, times negative one.
Time ten to the negative one Coulombs
and we're going to take
the absolute value of this
so that negative is going to go away.
All of that over, all of that over
and we're in kind of the
home stretch right over here,
0.5 meters squared.
And so, let's just do a
little bit of the math here.
So first of all, let's look at the units.
So we have Coulomb squared here,
then we're going to have
Coulombs times Coulombs there
that's Coulombs squared
divided by Coulombs squared
that's going to cancel with that and that.
You have meters squared here,
and actually let me just write it out,
so the numerator, in the numerator,
we are going to have
so if we just say nine times five
times, when we take the absolute value,
it's just going to be one.
So nine times five is going to be,
nine times five times negative...
five times negative one is negative five,
but the absolute value there,
so it's just going to be five times nine.
So it's going to be 45
times 10 to the nine,
minus three, minus one.
So six five,
so that's going to be 10 to the fifth,
10 to the fifth, the Coulombs
already cancelled out,
and we're going to have
Newton meter squared over,
over 0.25
meters squared. These cancel.
And so we are left with,
well if you divide by 0.25,
that's the same thing as dividing by 1/4,
which is the same thing
as multiplying by four.
So if you multiply this times four,
45 times four is 160
plus 20 is equal to 180
times 10 to the fifth Newtons.
And if we wanted to write
it in scientific notation,
well we could divide this by,
we could divide this by 100
and then multiply this by 100
and so you could write this as 1.80
times one point...
and actually I don't
wanna make it look like
I have more significant
digits than I really have.
1.8 times
10 to the seventh,
times 10 to the seventh units,
I just divided this by 100
and I multiplied this by 100.
And we're done.
This is the magnitude of
the electrostatic force
between those two particles.
And it looks like it's fairly significant,
and this is actually a good amount,
and that's because this is
actually a good amount of charge,
a lot of charge.
Especially at this
distance right over here.
And the next thing we have to think about,
well if we want not just the magnitude,
we also want the direction,
well, they're different charges.
So this is going to be
an attractive force.
This is going to be an
attractive force on each of them
acting at 1.8 times ten
to the seventh Newtons.
If they were the same charge,
it would be a repulsive force,
or they would repel each
other with this force.
But we're done.